Sometimes certain situations in life have
you wishing for a quick way out.
Waiting to have a meeting with your boss,
heading into an important test, or getting
ready to have an awkward conversation with
a romantic partner who just texted that “we
need to talk”.
All of these can be pretty hard to deal with.
In times like these, it can be easy to want
to run away.
We feel a part of ourselves saying that it
would be better to just bail out as quickly
as we can.
But just because choosing to make an exit
is often the quickest way to avoid a problem,
that doesn’t always mean it’s the best
solution - especially when your means of escape
venture into the world of the anomalous.
Sometimes you have to face things head on,
but if you are still really in need of a quick
way out, then SCP-120 might just be what you
are looking for.
But don’t say we didn’t warn you.
Now, hear us out.
Yes, we know that it’s a children’s paddling
pool.
You might have even owned one yourself back
in the day.
When the warm summer months came rolling around,
your younger self would have begged your poor
parents to spend several minutes in the sun’s
glaring heat, breathlessly inflating a pool
just like it, then filling it with water from
the garden hose.
All so you could put on your water wings,
have a splash around for an hour or two, then
go inside to dry off.
The result?
Leaving the water in that paddling pool to
go stagnant as it got left outside in the
summer sun, filled with dirt, leaves, and
mosquito larvae while you decided that air
conditioning and Super Mario was a better
way to spend your time.
But SCP-120, as will likely come as no surprise,
is no ordinary children’s paddling pool.
Sure, it might look like an ordinary paddling
pool at first: Pastel pink in color, only
two and a half meters in diameter, and less
than a meter tall.
It’s even made out of that same typical
flimsy plastic that needs to be inflated with
air to hold a shape.
You know, the kind that absorbed all that
heat from the sunlight while your younger
self was out there splashing around, just
waiting to burn your skin at the slightest
touch.
But the first key difference between SCP-120
and the pool you had while you were growing
up is, well, this one is indestructible.
Despite being made from common Earth plastics,
SCP-120 cannot be damaged or destroyed by
any conventional means.
Though the material it is made from will still
flex when pressure is applied, and is soft
to the touch, it also possesses an anomalous
tensile strength.
In other words, SCP-120 cannot be ripped,
stretched, or otherwise destroyed like an
ordinary paddling pool can.
And the SCP Foundation would know, they’ve
destroyed their own fair share of paddling
pools in the research labs.
Okay, so SCP-120 is an indestructible child’s
paddling pool, surely there has to be more
to it than that?
Otherwise, why would it be such an important
object to the SCP Foundation?
Well, you’re right, there’s much more
to it than that.
After all, they don’t call it the Teleporting
Paddling Pool for nothing.
Within the pool itself is a glowing substance,
almost like a liquid but somehow unlike any
in existence, at least in this dimension.
What exactly do we mean by that?
Well, this “liquid” doesn’t behave in
quite the same way you would expect from,
say, water, for example, and its physical
properties don’t align with the rules of
our universe.
Let’s say, you fill your ordinary paddling
pool with water, just like you would have
done on a hot summer day as a kid.
Now, because of the properties of the water,
you know you could easily grab a drinking
glass from your kitchen cabinet and fill it
up from the pool no problem.
However, the substance within SCP-120 does
not obey these same rules, you simply cannot
grab a glass or other container and scoop
up some of this glowing liquid.
See what we mean?
The “liquid” is only really a liquid in
name and can’t be manipulated in the same
way that an ordinary liquid can.
However, it does also share the appearance
of being a liquid, with its surface rippling
and shimmering often as it moves.
So, put all of that together and what is the
conclusion you get?
That this substance definitely does not exist
in our own dimension, instead it is from somewhere
else entirely.
By far the biggest difference between SCP-120
and any ordinary pastel pink colored WalMart
paddling pool is the property that the Foundation
is most interested in.
In fact, this paddling pool is part of that
oh-so-rare category of SCPs that actually
have a practical use, thanks to this anomalous
property: Human beings, along with the clothes
they’re wearing and any items they might
be carrying, will be teleported to one of
eleven different locations should they fall
into the paddling pool.
To reiterate, they don’t call it the Teleporting
Paddling Pool for nothing.
There are some small limitations to SCP-120’s
teleportation ability.
For one, the weight of objects or loads being
carried through it by one person cannot exceed
the maximum threshold of just under thirty
eight kilos, or almost eighty four pounds.
There are also only eleven destinations that
SCP-120 can send someone to, and these can’t
be pre-programmed or predetermined beforehand.
Any subjects stepping into the pool must be
conscious, carrying weight under the specified
amount, be biologically a human being and
can only use the Teleporting Paddling Pool
one person at a time.
Meeting these requirements means that the
pool will work as expected.
The only repercussion of not meeting the aforementioned
criteria is simply that the pool will not
function.
Any who have stepped into the pool carrying
too much weight for example, have merely reported
that their feet touch the surface beneath
the glowing ‘liquid’.
First encountered by the SCP Foundation in
September 1992, SCP-120 was found in California
following reports of children going missing
in the area.
There they discovered the Teleporting Paddling
Pool, and brought it back to Site 19 for testing.
It is currently unknown how many children
went missing, or if they were ever recovered.
Regardless, remember how we talked about making
a quick exit at the start of this video?
Well, that’s because the Foundation’s
biggest interest in SCP-120 was to use it
as a means of rapid evacuation for their most
important group of people - the Overwatch
Command, also known as the O5 Council.
During a major emergency like a containment
breach, the O5s would use the paddling pool
to escape to safety.
As you may have already gathered from how
we’ve described it, SCP-120 has the inert
ability to instantly relocate a person from
one place to another.
According to the theories of the SCP Foundation’s
researchers, it likely does this by allowing
the subject to pass through one or more dimensions
alternate to our own.
We also mentioned that one of the limits of
SCP-120 is that it can only send someone to
one of eleven different places.
These are distinguished by the liquid-like
substance contained in SCP-120 undergoing
a change of color.
By sending disposable members of D Class personnel
carrying radio beacons through, the Foundation
has been able to compile a list of these destinations,
and they are as follows:
The first of these is the Pacific Ocean, denoted
by a blue glow of SCP-120’s liquid.
When traveling here, subjects are deposited
around two meters above the surface of the
Pacific.
Since this location was discovered during
testing, a Foundation vessel named the SCPS
Demeter has been stationed at these coordinates.
To the public, this ship is known instead
as the USS Nassau, operating under the cover
story of being a simple meteorological boat.
But why would the Foundation leave a boat
here?
The current position of this ship means that
anyone traveling to the Pacific through the
Teleporting Paddling Pool will appear in the
vessel’s cargo hold.
In a crisis, important personnel could be
sent to the Demeter, and the boat could even
be used to hold less dangerous SCP objects,
if they could be sent through SCP-120.
Of course, teleporting oneself aboard a boat
might be a bit trickier, say, during a storm.
If the Demeter is moved too far from its current
position, there’s a chance someone might
end up teleporting inside one of the ship’s
walls.
The next location is Greenland, where SCP-120
will send someone when its liquid glows white.
Arriving here, one will find themself in a
facility that the Foundation has established
on site.
The cover story for this one is that this
building is part of an expansion of the oil
industry.
What members of the public are not privy to
is the true function of the facility.
The Foundation set this site up specifically
to perform the same function as their ship
the Demeter.
The facility even has an airstrip and a refueling
station there, meaning any who use the paddling
pool to teleport to Greenland can further
relocate themselves aboard a Foundation aircraft
if necessary.
If the liquid in SCP-120 ever changes to become
a deep black in color, it will then lead to
one of five possible points that are all practically
identical.
These destinations are various Earth-Moon
Lagrange Points.
In celestial mechanics, a Lagrange Point is
an area near two large bodies orbiting in
space.
To put it in simple terms, in this case, these
are points between the Earth and the Moon
where the gravitational forces of both balance
each other out.
This is what makes these Lagrange Points such
good locations for satellites, as the equal
forces make it easier for a satellite to achieve
the right path of orbit.
So, objects or people sent through SCP-120
when the water blackens will end up at either
Lagrange Point 1, 2, 3, 4 or 5.
These points are located all the way around
the Earth, and are directly between the Earth
and the Moon whenever the latter makes its
orbit around the former.
Essentially, jumping through the Teleporting
Paddling Pool when it has been “dialed”
to one of these locations is like taking the
high dive into the cold, endless vacuum of
space, ending up lost forever, impossible
to retrieve.
The SCP Foundation plans to potentially use
these SCP-120 destinations to dispose of anomalous
objects during a crisis, as a way to prevent
them from falling into the wrong hands.
Now, we mentioned that SCP-120’s “liquid”
will glow white when it’s linked to the
destination in Greenland, but the same also
occurs when it is dialed to the snow capped
mountains of the Himalayas.
This famous mountain range in Southern and
Eastern Asia is home to a number of Planet
Earth’s tallest peaks.
Most notably Mount Everest, the highest mountain
in the world, resting at the border between
Nepal and China.
Unlike some of the other destinations, the
Foundation has made little change to this
one.
No boats or bases for anyone to materialize
into safety have been designated to the area.
Instead, there’s just an eight meter hole
where the bodies of D Class test subjects
have been disposed of, hidden from view by
a canopy.
Only in extreme cases would the O5 Council
ever want to evacuate to here.
Should SCP-120 display a yellow glow, then
someone traveling through it will arrive in
the Sahara Desert, in Africa.
The Sahara is famous for being the largest
hot desert in the entire world, only beaten
in size by the northern Arctic and Antarctic
deserts.
Located here is a much smaller Foundation
installation, an outpost that would most likely
be ineffective for housing anomalous objects,
but in an evacuation could prove a useful
hiding place for important SCP documents,
or even for members of the Overwatch Command.
If SCP-120 produces a brown glow in its liquid,
it will transport a subject to the Gobi Desert,
a region in northern China and southern Mongolia
famous for its unique ecosystem.
Here, much like the Sahara location, the Foundation
has established an identical small outpost.
However, this one does come with the threat
of another anomaly, SCP-4024.
This is a saltwater spring that is gradually
expanding across the Gobi, which, much like
the Teleporting Paddling Pool, has the ability
to displace people and objects to an unknown
location.
Finally, should SCP-120 ever emit a subdued,
gray-colored glow, traveling through it will
lead to an area in the Sea of Rains.
But that’s not a sea on Earth, that’s
on the Moon.
And it’s not so much a “sea” as it is
a vast plain.
Luckily, if you were to end up here, the Foundation
has already thought ahead and set up a station
on the lunar surface, and it’s thought to
be one of their safest.
So, at least if the Teleporting Paddling Pool
sent you to the moon, you would be able to
survive.
That’s reassuring.
Of course, the real problem is, how do you
get back home?
That’s a question for another day.
Just like we told you at the start of this
video, sometimes it’s better to just face
your problems head-on, because certain escapes
can lead to more complications than you bargained
for.
Now go check out “Minecraft World Destroyer
SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible” and “SCP-5094
- Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse” for more
SCPs that put the strange into your childhood
joys!